in nba circles earlier this season in
the game at the clippers
in which he came out with 39 points
quick strike back to hawke's version of
al horford who averaged 18 points and
17 and another but i really like here
they wait for you to drop that ball down
below if you're big and go get it damian
lillard
from distance the matchup and richardson
wasn't having it
dame races to the cup and one or gold at
the cup
going back to what he started the game
with
just attacking head down one man to beat
basket that
usually will open up driving lanes dame
does not need it
the blazers will get philadelphia to
side out but zach flips the side
gives name a chance to go up there with
shots like that
good pass back door
[Applause]
energy but he will dunk when the time
calls for when he needs to route his
team up a little bit
richardson really up in the grill of
damian lillard here eight seconds
dame able to force the foul the bucket
and
damian lillard lies in how you're being
played richardson
not relenting at all all up in them
and they have not dropped blazers trying
to extend the lead here
dame wants another three it's okay to be
green
just set up the usage of the screen
dude dirk was standing there
133 left dame working damien lillard
give me 51.
look at that basket from damian he's
looking to the left because cj's coming
up to try to set a screen but
philadelphia took that away by playing
the high side on scene